so uh what's lovehino about
wait have you not read orshlockhin no i
don't know i don't know really i don't
know anything about love you know wow
love hina okay
this
i'm i'ma say right now this is nostalgia
i mean look i'll come on skins this is
amazing
explain yourself what is it about it's
nothing you haven't heard before yeah um
it's it's a manga where a guy loves hina
oh for [ __ ] sake
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it interesting
okay so a guy
um a guy moves into this to
uh her his grandma's onsen right because
uh his grandma owns a nonsense
uh and uh it turns out it's also a
girl's dormitory and uh
and uh okay it's a [ __ ] haram anime
okay it's it's sorry it's a harry manga
okay
and uh how can i say this it's uh
classic it's it's it's just a solid
harry manga and i there's there's
nothing i can do to convince you to
watch it i i i'm not gonna try and
convince you to read it okay i'm not i'm
not i'm not here this isn't for you
connor this is for me this is for me
this is this is god's go 100 honestly
this was the very first manga i have
ever read oh really yeah yeah yeah
out of everything right because i
remember watching it was the first anime
i ever watched because before that i had
this like first anime no i'm sorry sorry
it's the first animal you're gonna say
this is the first anime this is the
first anime i watched where
before that i had this massive complex
against manga right because i was like i
know because like i've discriminated
against manga honestly honestly because
i'm like how can you get into black and
white drugs i'm sorry i'm sorry this is
disgusting this is for peasants western
western comics go through the trouble of
coloring in where's the movement where's
the color where's the color i'm just
like how am i supposed to get into this
and like love hina was the first anime i
watched where i'm just like
i want to see what happens
i'll fight through the black and white i
want to see what happens enough that
i'll [ __ ] read the monkey she looks
cute but she looks like a like a pokemon
reject
um she's uh i think every character in
the 90s yeah yeah it's true because i
think they all had like the same kind of
thing so out of ten
i mean i i've
just give me give me your [ __ ] score
gone what is it
that that stutter was a five
thing i i think loving it to this day is
like a solid six or seven
i think it's just a fun six or seven
it's a [ __ ] if if you like harry
manga
which you don't
so okay if you like harriman i still
think lafina is such is a very very sort
of power it still stands up to us why do
you love
so much like what about the harem speaks
to you god oh that's like girls eh
i want all the girls okay
i'll i'll break it down okay because
this is gonna be a really weird analogy
um if i'm like if there's a harem manga
that i'm invested in it's not it's not
specifically about oh there's a bunch of
girls what i equate reading a harry
manga to it's kind of like watching us
watching a sports match right because
like you're gonna [ __ ] say that yeah
yeah cause okay because pick your team
when you root for them you pick your
team and you get emotionally invested
right
you pick your best girl and
you [ __ ] root for them and you stick
through it through thick and thin yeah
and then
even if they don't win
they've won in your heart yeah if even
if they don't win but if they do win
it's like it's it's such an emotion rush
because
yes
yes you literally become a [ __ ]
sports fan i bet god's never as happy as
when his [ __ ] harem
part of the best part of harems right is
being he's watching it with the
community because like half the fun is
seeing your girl win but also half the
fun is [ __ ] on the fans of the
losing girl as well that's like that's
like equally as [ __ ] that's what i loved
about it 100 because i read it with a
bunch of my japanese friends who were
all just as invested and they all had
their own winners and when i when my
girl won i was like [ __ ] you
i told you he had the biggest dick that
week i did i felt good
okay so like i mean it's i still think
it's a solid harem i think one of the
biggest differences to a lot of harems i
met is that i do like the character
development of the main guy he starts
off as obviously a [ __ ] loser with no
personality but as the series goes on he
actually develops why don't we ever get
chad
because they wouldn't be interested it
would be a hentai a chance you become
more
that's the difference we had
where's where's the space for growth if
they're already attracted to become more
modest
maybe they love modesty oh who wants to
see that i want to see a man learn more
[Music]
he goes from like this brick [ __ ] house
brood it's just the guy who's too full
of himself just gets modest
i'm sure that exists somewhere